as anyone familiar with series creator
George Lucas's original Star Wars
screenplay would tell you the process of
making the first film so special
involved throwing a lot of bad ideas
away so while most of the series worst
moments are confined to the three
prequels the movie that started it all
had plenty of cringe-worthy material
going into it which many of Lucas's
collaborators wisely fought to prune
appearing on The Tonight Show Starring
Johnny Carson shortly after the Star
Wars mania had begun to sweep the nation
in 1977 Mark Hamill
shared his own contribution to the
scripts improvement revealing one
clunkers of a line from the original
screenplay he talked to Lucas out of the
dialogue was a little bit difficult I
remember there was one line that I just
begged him to take out of the screen
plane he finally did I'll never forget
it as long as I live I sometimes dream
about this line the passage in question
came up during a scene in which the crew
of the Millennium Falcon comes across
what remains of Princess Leia's home
planet Alderaan after it's been
destroyed by the Death Star the line
Hamill protested came as a response from
Luke to a remark by han Solo which
Hamill quotes for Carson with a
charmingly gruff Harrison Ford
impression and Harrison says look I've
done my part of the bargain when I get
to an asteroid you the old man and the
droids get dropped off that line in and
of itself wouldn't have been too out of
the ordinary for the swashbuckling space
man but what would have come next was
pretty ridiculous and my line was but we
can't turn back fear is their greatest
defense I doubt if the actual security
there is any greater than it was on
aquilae or solace and what there is is
most likely directed towards a
large-scale assault even in a script
filled with confusing exchanges that one
was too much for Hamill and I thought
who talks like this your
the line would have still been far from
the worst bit of dialogue ever to be
uttered in the series but you can see
why Hamill wouldn't want to try and
deliver those words Hamill remembered
pleading for the lines removal out of a
sense of self-preservation this is
really not fair because you know we're
the ones that are gonna get vegetables
thrown at us not you the presence of the
planet names aqua ley and Sullust in the
convoluted line serves to demonstrate
just how much got chiseled away from
Star Wars script on its way from page to
screen in the original story treatment
aqua lay was a fleshed-out planet with
the real world parallel of communist
North Vietnam by the time the movie was
shooting the names had been reduced to a
reference for the sake of world building
when Hamill prevailed in removing the
one line they appeared in he deleted the
planets entirely the line that haunted
Hamill isn't the only part of Star Wars
original script that needed work and
Hamels not the only actor who had issues
Harrison Ford who plays the space pirate
in the film at one point threatened to
tie George up and and make him say his
own lines at gunpoint while the cast
complaints with the script may have
caused some friction their efforts
worked to sand down Star Wars rough
edges making it so most of the worst
stuff never made it out of the editing
Bay it all goes to show that when it
comes to collaboration compromise is
king
otherwise you get the Phantom Menace and
how many great lines can you quote from
that film Arthur no place is terrible
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]